I've thought about how to teach this
many different ways I guess has the
privilege of being able to do it many
times and I remember thinking she is is
what not to do as a teacher you're like
I understand like this so they've all
just explained Olympians that's like
committing suicide for a teacher because
by the time you understand it you will
explain it away which is actually not
very helping people we've never met the
idea before okay sir
this is what textbooks do and it's also
what the programs do is I'd actually
would like me to get these five steps
now to get to these geometric functions
and their derivatives takes a lot of
work there's five at least five distinct
steps that are each bill wrap or one
another for example you get sort of
results for here and then you use that
the next step it's like one of those
ball for example question so it's a paw
day and then the next bit is like hits
you know using pas de doing this blah
blah blah and then you know by the time
you get to pot f you know your ears are
bleeding etc but there is logic to it
okay in that each subsequent step uses
results that you develop in the previous
steps the problem with it is we're
trying to work at the derivatives are in
function like this this is sine X right
that you might as well for that and by
the way while you wait sorry
it says squeeze law is a legit
mathematical law or squeeze ball will
get
now here's the way works in a textbook
you're reading this right and it starts
off saying we got different cheese and
treat functions and then it starts off
having nothing to do with calculus at
all and then introduces this weird thing
with inequalities which is like why why
are we doing this and then you
eventually gets your best principals and
then they say okay is there as always
proved it we've derived it now look at
it you're like only makes sense now I
think that's exactly backwards gentlemen
I think this is result Australia this
border is exactly backwards okay so this
starts with abstract stuff and you like
what is it to do anything okay so I'm
gonna take is for dark and almost
completely i stuff it in two and three
in the same order but everything else
I'm gonna flip on its head so I'm gonna
start five I'm gonna weigh all the way
back up to one okay but to do that
because I told you each step relies on
the previous steps so what we're doing
say step 4 but that's an important one
I've gotta use the result that we're
gonna have to prove it earliest steps
but I'm just gonna show it to you and
I'm just gonna sort of say look it works
let's not worry about why it works and
the exact mechanics of it just stay with
me and we'll prove it afterwards okay so
he's where we gonna begin
apply some intuition let's just use our
brains okay here is sine X so let's see
we shall write this and as you'll see
shortly we've got three basic trig
functions outside cost and if you and
outside you get all the rest okay it's
really quite simple so if we can work
out what's the derivative what is its
gradient function then we're off and
away
so things to those I've only drawn part
of sine X yes I've drawn it from 0 to
360 which is one period okay but there's
more to it I could keep going
but I don't need to why not why don't I
need to draw any of the rest of this
graphically
because I've got a whole cycle of it
sign and all the trig functions I will
be call periodic right namely they
repeat over and over again over a given
period it's periodic so being that this
function is periodic it's repetitive I'm
going to say therefore the derivative of
therefore the derivative of this
function which is just describing its
gradient but similarly be periodic does
that make sense because all the
derivative is telling us is gradient
okay and if this is what the function is
doing its gradient will be doing the
same thing it's gonna repeat forever
okay so there's the first thing we know
about it that whatever result we're
gonna get the people you know it's gonna
be a repeating function and that narrows
it down quite significant okay now what
else can we see about this graph well
our gradient is easiest to illustrate
when you figure out tangents okay so for
instance I can put some tangents on here
like say at this point that would be a
tangent right and yeah there'd be
another tangent these are the particular
spots x equals 90 degrees and x equals
270 degrees okay now see is those
tangents at least if your drawing is
pretty sure those changes are horizontal
what does that imply about the gradient
at those points zero right horizontal
line it's flat as they rise to the
gradient I'm gonna plot according to
another color in green okay on the same
graph the grade function should be zero
at 90 degrees and it should be zero at
two to seven degrees
okay so try to pin down what's this
what's this thing doing now that's not
all I can also say as I go from zero up
to ninety degrees okay do you see the
gradient is positive those are plus
signs if you can't quite make it out
so therefore whatever gradient function
I've got from zero and a degrees should
be positive and it's not just any
positive right it's most positive
steepest if you like at zero and then it
gets progressively more shallow so the
gradient is something steep ER and it's
approaching zero at that point okay so
the gradient here is positive and
decreasing that is the middle section
here between 90 and 270 okay how would
you describe it the gradient is what
sign is gradient negative tripe is a
decreasing function so negative all the
way through young and it's not just
negative we can also send say something
Bad's magnitude right it starts at zero
and it's a little bit negative kicks to
stupid shadow up here right where is the
steepest point where is it boost
negative when it crosses namely at the
axis right so actually about zero but
actually hundred eighty degrees right
that's the value when I'm interested in
okay so what are we said so far it's
zero here it gets progressively steeper
and nobody gets to here it starts to
slow down again and it starts to get
less negative until it comes back to
zero at this point okay and then the
last bit is really much like this it's
positive positive positive and it's the
most positive at that point and then the
whole thing starts art so what kind of
function fits these kinds of things
these kinds of characters do you have
nine degrees here 270 here okay it's
gotta go down then sorry yeah down and
then back up again right and it's gotta
be periodic okay so if you draw it in
and by the way you can actually show you
by measurement that they're grading at
the steepest points it's one here and
negative one here okay so the grading is
actually equal to one at that point
it's one here it's positive and then
it's decreasing until it hits zero at
this point it's zero sorry negative
negative negative at that point the
gradient function the green line is much
negative that corresponds to the actual
function side being the steepest in the
negative direction okay and then it does
the reverse over here it's still
negative but it's less negative until
that point the gradient function the
green one is zero which corresponds to a
horizontal tangent and then i makea it's
positive and that's the steepest that's
the highest it gets
now what's this green function this
green punch is Scott's okay so um we can
say the derivative of sine X well it
sure looks like coz X okay it seems to
tick all the boxes